i just want to bring you some breaking
news now that we've just
got in and the labour leader sakir stama
his office has issued this statement
uh one of sakiyasanam's children has
tested positive for covert this
lunchtime and
in line with the rules kier and his
family will now be
self-isolating kia was already doing
daily tests
and tested negative this morning he will
continue
to take daily tests well let's bring our
chief political correspondent john
craig and the labour leader essentially
part of the pindemic
indeed this is the fourth time sir
kirstama
has been forced to isolate the first was
in september last year
then again in december then again in
january
and now in july it comes just after
um prime minister's questions when the
pm was isolating
and the labour leader was in the chamber
and obviously
the plenty of exchanges about the ping
demik
uh the labor leader used this phrase
about uh
the prime minister he said that when it
comes to the pindemic
uh the uh the prime minister is a super
spreader of confusion
he caught he mocked the prime minister
called him the checkers one
well it seems that sekir is now the
kentish town one
that's the area of north london in the
borough of camden where he lives
so um one of his children has tested
positive
and uh the fact the whole family are
going to be self-isolating
it says the statement says he's been
doing daily tests
tested negative this morning and he will
continue to take daily tests so a blow
for the labour leader
like the prime minister a lot of it's
very inconvenient
because of course both the pm and the
leader of the opposition got all sorts
of visits planned
prime minister's had to do a news
conference already this week virtually
he's going to have to address tory mps
for the traditional end of term pep talk
tonight virtually
the labour leader he saw pictures of him
there a moment or two that was at the
winter gardens in blackpool
he like a lot of opposition party
leaders he's planning like a summer tour
uh in his case wants to get people to
know him better
labor struggling a bit in the polls at
the moment or what they want
today has showed them narrowing the gap
so a blow for the labour leader
but at least i suppose you could say
it's coming just before parliament
breaks up
but he will have to change his plans
just as boris johnson
had to at the weekend